alfred de vigny disait des habitants de
tours que leur langage était le plus
beau de france sans lenteur sans vitesse
sans accent le berceau de la langue est
là près du berceau de la monarchie
question quelle empreinte la cour at
elle laissé dans la façon de parler dans
la vallée de la loire la touraine a
simplement modifié ou en tout cas parler
d'une façon plus plus habituel le
françaises ile de france mais sans les
intonations faubourienne derrière nous
aujourd'hui où le populaire de la
capitale
cette réputation du beau-parent les
tourangeaux qui date de plusieurs
siècles est elle toujours valable pour
en savoir plus nous rencontrons un
spécialiste des sciences du langage à
l'université
d'après ses recherches le français parlé
à tour serait très proche du français
dits de référence une sorte de norme
régi par l'académie française et
l'office de la langue française très
proche oui mais avec quelques
spécificités locales au niveau de la
prononciation
par exemple on va dire le lait pour le
liquide blanc c'est le lait alors que
normalement on devrait produire le lait
ont deux on doit pouvoir faire la
distinction entre et et est en finale de
mots à tours environ la moitié des
locuteurs ne vont pas produire ils
entendent mais ne vont pas forcément
produire cette distinction ils vont
neutraliser cette distinction en
français de référence au bois donc du
lait et on mange du poulet
qu'en est il des tourangeaux et de leur
beau parler alors c'est laid et poulet
les poubelles les poulets les poulets
les poulets et si finalement la
spécificité locale était plutôt le
tourangeau le patois des anciens où l'on
roule les r le parler du monde rural en
entendant les marchés d
des campagnes c'est des choses courantes
dont on a l'habitude de pratiquer alors
effectivement par exemple aller là
berouette pour la brute est allé
chercher le sio pour donner le grand
toulouse et puis voilà la météo à
bernaches et quand le tance l'otan sans
brume
ne soyez pas étonnés si un jour un
ancien vous demande où il peut lâcher de
l'eau en patois tourangeau il vous
demande simplement
où sont les toilettes